I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Happy New Year. Happy 2021, everybody. Wow. This is exciting. We're in a new year. Man, oh, man. New year. I'm in a new size pants. I really am. I went up a whole pants. I made some New Year's resolutions, Jenna. And one of them is I'm going to move more. I'm going to keep it really simple. I'm just going to move more. You know, I did that, Ange, because
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》的终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。新年快乐。2021年大家新年快乐。哇。这太令人兴奋了。我们迎来了新的一年。天哪。新的一年。我穿的新尺码的裤子。真的。我整整大了一个裤码。珍娜，我做了一些新年决心。其中之一就是我要多运动。我要保持非常简单。我只是要多运动。你知道的，安吉，我那样做是因为
I felt really creaky when I would wake up in the morning. And I didn't like it. I felt like the age in my bones, you know? And I was like, you know, keep it in motion. It's a good thing. Yeah. I'm just going to go on more walks. This is my big New Year's resolution. More walking. I think that's good. Movement, fresh air. It's good for your health in so many ways. Yeah. I'm for this. I can't make my resolutions too complicated or it won't happen. So I'm keeping it real simple. Make attainable goals. This is amazing. I'm going to walk with you. Yay. Well, I'm excited. We'll do it together. Well, you guys, we are sorry you had to wait so long for part two, but we were, we were just wanting to spend
我早上醒来时感觉骨头特别僵硬。我不喜欢这种感觉。我觉得那是骨头变老的感觉，你知道吗？然后我想，你知道的，保持运动。这是件好事。是的。我只是想去多散步。这是我最大的新年决心。多走路。我觉得这挺好的。运动，新鲜空气。在很多方面对你的健康都有好处。是的。我支持这个。我不能把我的决心定得太复杂，否则就无法实现。所以我让它保持非常简单。设定切实可行的目标。这太棒了。我要跟你一起去。太好了。我很高兴。我们会一起去的。各位，很抱歉让大家等了这么久才看到第二部分，但我们只是想花点
some time with our families and we're excited to share with you now Dunder Mifflin Infinity part two. Yeah. And I have to say it's worth the wait because Michael's going to drive his car into a lake this week. Oh, and we have lots to say about it. We do. Let's get started. Let's do it. Dunder Mifflin Infinity part two, season four, episode four, written by Mike Sher and directed by Craig Zisk. Here is a summary. Michael tries to show up Ryan and his emphasis on technology by winning back clients with old fashioned customer service and elaborate gift baskets. Along the way, he drives into a lake after misinterpreting the directions from his GPS. Also in this episode, Ryan asked Pam to design some logos
时间陪伴家人，现在我们很高兴与大家分享《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第二部分。是的。而且我必须说，这绝对值得等待，因为迈克尔这周要把他的车开进湖里。哦，我们有很多话要说。我们确实有很多话要说。让我们开始吧。开始吧。《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第二部分，第四季第四集，由迈克·舒尔编剧，克雷g·齐斯克执导。以下是剧情摘要。迈克尔试图通过老式的客户服务和精美的礼品篮来赢回客户，以证明自己和瑞安对技术的重视。在这个过程中，他因误解了GPS的导航指令，把车开进了湖里。在这一集中，瑞安还请帕姆为
for Dunder Mifflin Infinity. And then he asks her out. And Angela makes it clear to Dwight that they are done. Yeah, she is not forgiving him. Well, gang, since we did fast facts on the first half of this episode, and since it is a new year, we thought we should pay a visit to our mailbag and answer some questions. Yes, it's time to talk to you guys. Well, our first letter came from Jesse S. And she said, Hi, I am a hard of hearing person who loves to listen to the podcast. But I do miss some things as I rely on lip reading a lot. I am wondering if transcribing the podcast is an option for other deaf and hard of hearing who are fans of the show and would love to be able to interact with the podcast. Well,
《邓德·米夫林无限公司》设计一些标志。然后他约了她。安吉拉向德怀特表明，他们彻底结束了。是的，她才不会原谅他呢。各位，既然我们在这一集的前半部分做过了快速事实回顾，而且正好又是新年，我们觉得应该去看看我们的信箱并回答一些问题。是的，是时候和大家聊聊了。我们的第一封信来自杰西·S。她说，嗨，我是一个有听力障碍的人，非常喜欢听这个播客。但我确实错过了一些内容，因为我非常依赖读唇语。我想知道，为剧集的粉丝中其他失聪和听力障碍群体提供播客文字记录是否是一个可行的选项，他们一定会非常喜欢并能够与播客互动。各位，
guys, we do have a transcription for every single episode going back to the pilot. And you can find it on officeladies.com. If you go to the episodes and scroll down, there's a little button for transcript. Yes, you go past the sort of summary of the episode. And it's right there. And you can click on it and read the whole thing. This is kind of personal to me, Jesse, because my sister, Emily, wears hearing aids. And she also relies on lip reading. And so I know that sometimes being able to both listen and read along is really helpful for her. And also, like when I go to her house, she always has the closed caption on her TV. So we definitely, definitely want the podcast to be accessible to everyone.
实际上，我们为每一集节目都准备了文字记录，一直追溯到试播集。你可以在 officeladies.com 上找到它们。如果你进入剧集页面并往下滚动，就会看到一个文字记录的按钮。是的，越过剧集的内容摘要部分。它就在那里。你可以点击它并阅读完整内容。这对我来说有点私人意义，杰西，因为我的妹妹艾米莉戴着助听器。她也很依赖读唇语。所以我知道，有时既能听又能跟着读对她来说真的很有帮助。而且，就像我去她家时，她的电视总是开着隐藏字幕。所以我们绝对、绝对希望这个播客能让每个人都能无障碍收听。
So guys, if there's any other ways we can make it more accessible, let us know. Yes. And in the meantime, go to officeladies.com and go to each episode and scroll down and their transcript is right there. And we have a team here at Ear Wolf that helps us with that. And we so appreciate it. All right. Well, our next question, Jenna, comes from Julie Weiss. And she says, I have a question about kissing the other actors. How do you prep for kissing someone that you are friends with, but not romantically involved with? Was it ever awkward? Oh, Julie. Julie, it's always awkward. It's always awkward. And thank goodness over the years, though, you do become such good friends that it's just like, okay, well,
所以大家，如果还有什么其他方法能让我们做得更好，请告诉我们。是的。同时，请访问 officeladies.com，进入每一集并向下滚动，文字记录就在那里。我们在 Ear Wolf 有一个团队专门协助我们处理这件事，我们非常感激。好的。我们的下一个问题，珍娜，来自朱莉·韦斯。她说，我有一个关于与其他演员接吻的问题。你如何为和一个是朋友但没有恋爱关系的某人接吻做准备？这曾经尴尬吗？哦，朱莉。朱莉，这总是很尴尬。总是很尴尬。不过谢天谢地，多年来，你们变成了非常好的朋友，以至于感觉就像是，好吧，
we'll just do this really quickly. But something that made it difficult for me, which maybe you wouldn't think about is that I often had to kiss Rainn Wilson. And for whatever reason, he was usually eating something disgusting right beforehand. And I'd be like, Rainn, dang it. Do you have to eat a tuna fish sandwich right before we're supposed to kiss? Come on. Yeah, I remember he would always be like downing a cup of coffee and an everything bagel. Yes. And he'd be like, I'm ready for my kissing scene. And you would be like, Rainn, a mint. Can you do something? Anything at this point, just not the everything bagel, anything out? My God. Well, at least for me, John was always very conscientious. He would
我们赶快把这个拍完吧。但有一件事让我觉得很难，也许这是你意想不到的，那就是我经常得和雷恩·威尔逊接吻。不管出于什么原因，他通常在接吻前刚吃过什么恶心的东西。我就会说，雷恩，该死。难道我们在需要接吻之前，你非得吃一个金枪鱼三明治吗？拜托。是的，我记得他总是会狂吞一杯咖啡和一个什锦百吉饼。是的。然后他会说，我已经准备好拍吻戏了。而你会说，雷恩，来块薄荷糖。你这时候能不能做点什么？随便什么都行，只要别吃那个什锦百吉饼，什么都行！天哪。好吧，至少对我来说，约翰一直非常注重这一点。他会
have a mint or some gum. A mint. Rainn Wilson, a mint. We were very breath aware. Rain, Rainn, not so much. Also, Julie, we didn't do the big open mouth stuff that maybe you see in movies and whatnot. This was like television. Comedy kissing is very different than like a dramatic movie, make out, you know, it's your lips are kind of just together, you know, you kind of fake it. Fakey kiss, fakey bag. Well, our next question comes from Jessica Willis. I've always been curious how much ADR did you have to typically do for your episodes? I've noticed that in some episodes, you see characters remove a mic pack and the audio goes black. It's such
吃一块薄荷糖或嚼口香糖。薄荷糖。雷恩·威尔逊，来块薄荷糖。我们对口气都非常在意。雷恩，雷恩可就没那么在意了。还有，朱莉，我们没有像你在电影里可能看到的那样进行那种大张嘴的法式热吻。这可是电视剧。喜剧里的接吻和那种戏剧电影里的热吻非常不同，你知道的，你们的嘴唇基本上只是贴在一起，你知道的，你只是在假装。假亲，假装。好吧，我们的下一个问题来自杰西卡·威利斯。我一直很好奇，为了你们的剧集，你们通常需要做多少台词补录（ADR）？我注意到在某些剧集中，你可以看到角色取下麦克风背包，然后音频就变黑了。这真是一个
a real cool detail and a reference to the documentary. So how much original audio did you use and how much was re-recorded after filming? Well, lady, my memory is we did not do a lot of ADR. I mean, I have one memory of the whole nine years of going in to do it. Yeah. In the entire nine years, I only recorded one line that they had to dub in later, one in nine years. And I thought that's how it worked. Yeah. And when I went on other jobs, part of your job is you go in a studio every week and you dub lines that got missed or that maybe a plane flew over your head or there was a sound problem and they dump it in and I'd spend maybe 30 minutes an hour just doing that on other shows. But on our
非常酷的细节，也是对纪录片的致敬。那么你们用了多少原始音频，有多少是在拍摄后重新录制的呢？好吧，女士，我的记忆是，我们没有做太多的 ADR。我的意思是，在整整九年的时间里，我对去做这事只有一个记忆。是的。在整整九年里，我只录过一句后来需要他们配音的台词，九年里只有一句。我还以为这就是工作流程呢。是的。当我参与其他工作时，你工作的一部分就是每周去录音室，为那些漏掉的台词配音，或者可能是有飞机从你头顶飞过，或者是遇到了声音问题，他们会把声音替换进去，在其他剧组里，我可能花大约 30 分钟到一个小时来做这件事。但在我们的
show, we did not. And why is that? Because all the other projects I've gone on, you have like an ADR day where you go in. But on the office, I only did ADR once and it was for the finale. And I got to see footage of the finale before it aired, before anyone saw it because I went in and had to loop one line. And it was because we were outside and we had that storm coming in and they just needed me to loop a line. And I even took a picture in the ADR booth because I'd never been in there. You know, first of all, our sound engineers were Emmy award winning. They won Emmys for
剧组里，我们没有。这是为什么呢？因为我去过的所有其他项目，你都会有一个专门的 ADR 日，你要去录音棚。但在《办公室》里，我只做过一次 ADR，那是在大结局的时候。而且我在大结局播出前、在任何人看到之前，就看到了它的片段，因为我去了并必须循环录制一句台词。那是因为我们在室外，当时有一场风暴正在逼近，他们只是需要我循环录制一句台词。我甚至还在 ADR 录音室里拍了张照片，因为我以前从没进去过。你知道，首先，我们的音响工程师是艾美奖得主。他们为我们剧集的
their sound design on our show. They're just amazing. But they also had a mic pack on every single actor. We had two boom operators in the room and they hid microphones throughout the office. I had one at reception. Oh, yeah, we had a microphone in the accounting pod and they put it next to Oscar's phone. So it would sort of pick up the three of us, you know. But I also remember I would often see our boom operators and camera operators having little powwows because they would have to choreograph the boom swing with the camera swing so that they could pick up the sound. And it was this crafted dance that they did.
声音设计赢得过艾美奖。他们太棒了。而且他们在每个演员身上都配了一个麦克风包。我们在房间里有两个挑杆收音师，他们在办公室各处藏了麦克风。我在前台有一个。哦，对，我们在会计区有一个麦克风，他们把它放在奥斯卡的电话旁边。这样它就能差不多收录我们三个人的声音，你知道的。但我也记得，我经常看到我们的挑杆收音师和摄像师在开小会，因为他们必须将挑杆的摆动与摄像机的摇动进行编排，以便他们能够收录声音。这是他们共同完成的一支精心设计的舞蹈。
And it's really amazing. And I'm actually glad that Jessica wrote in because it gives us a chance to really shout out our sound department, which was incredible. Our main guys that were with us on the stage were Ben Patrick. Yep. He was our main like production sound mixer sound editor. And we had our two boom operators, Nick Carbone. Don't get car boned. Don't get car boned. And Brian Whittle, Brian Whittle would be the inspiration for the boom operator that we see later in the story. Yeah, but then we also had like a mixing department and we had other boom operators and people that would rotate in. We just had a really
这真的很神奇。我其实很高兴杰西卡写信来，因为这让我们有机会真正感谢我们的音响部门，他们简直不可思议。和我们在片场一起的主要成员是本·帕特里克。对。他是我们的主要制作混音师兼音响编辑。我们还有两个挑杆收音师，尼克·卡博恩。别被卡博恩整了。别被卡博恩整了。还有布莱恩·惠特尔，布莱恩·惠特尔将成为我们在后面的故事中看到的那个挑杆收音师的原型。是的，但我们还有一个混音部门，我们有其他挑杆收音师和轮流上岗的人员。我们只是有一个非常
amazing sound team. Yeah, they were great. While we have one more question, this one is from Alicia W. She asked, in the talking heads where the camera is facing into the office, Stanley is almost always in the background. Would Leslie David Baker have to stay in the background the whole time they filmed talking heads or was that background edited in? Oh, Alicia, he had to sit there. Yes. For nine years. Poor Leslie David Baker. He was always in the background. He was always there. You could see him at his desk. And he was such a trooper. When people had talking heads, when we had a long day of them, he'd sit there. Yep.
出色的音响团队。是的，他们太棒了。好吧，我们还有一个问题，这个问题来自艾莉西亚·W。她问，在摄像机面向办公室的“谈话头”访谈中，斯坦利几乎总是出现在背景中。莱斯利·大卫·贝克在拍摄“谈话头”的整个过程中都必须一直待在背景里吗，还是说背景是后期编辑进去的？哦，艾莉西亚，他必须坐在那里。是的。整整九年。可怜的莱斯利·大卫·贝克。他总是出现在背景中。他一直都在那里。你可以看到他在他的办公桌前。他真是个硬汉。当大家进行“谈话头”访谈时，当我们有漫长的一天拍摄时，他一直坐在那里。是的。
And sometimes Phyllis would have to sit there and sometimes Creed as well. Yes. And early on, they would have people there designated to cross. Like you might see someone like Cross to the kitchen or Cross back. We abandoned that after a couple of seasons. I think if you look at early season talking heads, you see crosses in the background. And then at a certain point, people are like, I think, I'm thinking, no, I think I'm not going to go to the kitchen and back to get a cup of coffee for two hours. Yeah, I don't. Also, I think they were a little distracting because I know I did a Cross one time and they had me cross really close to the conference room, that cabinet that was
有时候菲利斯也得坐在那里，有时克里德也是。是的。早期的时候，他们会在那里安排一些人走过。比如你可能会看到某人走过走向厨房或走回来。几个季度后我们就放弃了这个做法。我想如果你看看早期的“谈话头”访谈，你会看到背景中有人走过。然后在某个时间点，大家觉得，我考虑了一下，不，我觉得我不会为了喝一杯咖啡而花两个小时走到厨房再走回来。是的，我才不呢。另外，我觉得他们有点分散注意力，因为我知道我有一次走过去，他们让我紧挨着会议室、挨着那个柜子走过去
there. And then they're like, oh, no. And then they had me cross way in the back. But I think ultimately they were just like, okay, no, no crossing. Well, also, if you wanted to improv, it would throw off the timing of the cross. Yeah. And so you would, when you went into editing, it did not work for crosses. It just worked to have poor Leslie at his desk as a constant Leslie and then Creed. I think Creed would be the number two runner up for that. I think so too. And then before we go to break, we just got a really nice comment and it made us happy. So we thought we'd share it. It is from Cecilia B. And she says, ladies, I have to tell you, you two are amazing. Thank you, Cecilia. I finally
就在那儿。然后他们说，哦，不。然后他们让我从很远后面走过去。但最终我想他们大概觉得，好吧，不，不要有人走来走去。好吧，另外，如果你想即兴发挥，这会打乱走路过场的时机。是的。所以当你进入剪辑时，走过过场行不通。只有让可怜的莱斯利坐在他的办公桌前作为一个恒定的存在才行，莱斯利还有克里德。我认为克里德会是这方面的第二名。我也这么认为。在我们进入休息时间之前，我们刚刚收到了一条非常好的评论，它让我们很开心。所以我们想分享它。它来自西西莉亚·B。她说，女士们，我必须告诉你们，你们两个太棒了。谢谢你，西西莉亚。我终于
got the courage to ask for our changes at work. And all I kept hearing was both of you ladies in my head saying, just go for it. Ask for what you want. And I'm so happy that I listened to you ladies. Now I get to have an extra hour with my daughters. I'm a single mom and every second with them counts. Thank you, ladies. Well, that makes me so happy. Aw. Well, Cecilia, that makes us so happy to hear. And what? Oh, Sam is waving at me. Jenna, before we go to break, Sam, what do you got? I want to let you guys know on the Office Ladies podcast fan page. I know you guys aren't on Facebook. We've heard of this though, Jenna. Yes. People have shared with us. So hi, you guys. Hello. There is a whole thread of people agreeing
鼓起勇气在工作中要求做出改变。我脑海里一直回响着你们两位女士的声音，说：“去争取吧。索取你想要的东西。”我很高兴我听了你们的话。现在我可以和我的女儿们多相处一个小时了。我是一个单亲妈妈，和她们在一起的每一秒都很重要。谢谢你们，女士们。这让我太开心了。啊。西西莉亚，听到这个我们太开心了。什么？哦，萨姆在向我挥手。珍娜，在我们休息之前，萨姆，你有什么事？我想让你们知道，在《办公室女士》播客粉丝专页上——我知道你们不上 Facebook。不过我们听说过这个，珍娜。是的。人们跟我们分享过。所以，嗨，大家好。你好。有一个讨论串，大家都在赞同
with Cecilia that had similar experiences. There's a woman named Naomi Timmer who went in and told her boss she deserved more money after listening to that episode and got a raise. And then there's a whole thread of people underneath it who'd realized that they had been operating the same way, negotiating themselves down before they went in the interview who are not going to do it anymore. Oh my gosh, that is so great. I love that you're all sharing about it too. I love that so much. It's awesome. Well, I feel like I should give a shout out to the person who gave me this piece of advice. His name is Jeff Ulrich. And ever since he told me this, it has really resonated with me. I've been like, oh my gosh, I've been negotiating with myself
西西莉亚，并且有相似的经历。有一个叫娜奥米·蒂默的女性，在听了那一集后，走进办公室告诉老板她应该得到更多薪水，然后真的加薪了。然后在这条下面有一整串人，他们意识到自己以前也是这样运作的，在进面试前就把自己的薪水往下谈，而他们再也不会这样做了。哦天哪，这太棒了。我很高兴你们都在分享这些。我太喜欢了。这太棒了。好吧，我觉得我应该向给我这个建议的人致敬。他的名字叫杰夫·乌尔里希。自从他告诉我这个之后，它真的深深触动了我。我一直觉得，哦天哪，我一辈子都在和自己讨价还价，拿著低于我应得的报酬。所以这对我来说也是一个新的建议。所以大家，我们都在一起努力。是的。
for less than I deserve my whole life. So this is a new piece of advice to me too. So we're all doing this together, folks. Yes. And Sam, thanks for sharing that. And I've been hearing about this Facebook fan group of Office Ladies. And I just love the community you guys are building there. And if I wasn't 100 years old, I don't know how to navigate Facebook. Guys, I tried. I don't understand it. But it's too many things too. I have to have just the one. That's the space I'm in. I know. I know. Like between kids and life, I'm like, I can look at one thing. But I will say someone did point this Facebook page out to us because the community that is being built there is really supportive, really encouraging, really positive. And I feel like
萨姆，谢谢你分享这个。我一直听说这个《办公室女士》的 Facebook 粉丝群。我真的很喜欢你们在那里建立的社区。如果我不是已经 100 岁了的话，我都不知道怎么使用 Facebook。各位，我试过了。我看不懂。而且事情也太多了。我只能应付一个。那就是我所处的世界。我懂。我懂。就像在孩子和生活之间，我觉得，我只能看一件事。但我必须说，确实有人向我们指出了这个 Facebook 页面，因为那里建立的社区真的非常支持、非常鼓舞人心、非常积极。我觉得
especially now, what a great community to have built. It's really cool. Yeah, it means a lot to us. And Sam, you'll have to continue to share with us. Sounds good. Okay. Yeah. Because if you peek in on the group, will you say what it's called again, Sam? It is simply the Office Ladies podcast fan page. Awesome. Well, we should go to break and get back and get into this episode. Let's do it. All right. Now we're in Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 2. It starts with a scene in the conference room, right? Michael is showing them all the gift baskets. But Jenna, there was a deleted scene that would have started this part of the episode. What was it? I loved it. I found it fascinating.
特别是现在，能建立这样一个伟大的社区。这真的很酷。是的，这对我们意义重大。萨姆，你得继续跟我们分享。听起来不错。好的。好的。因为如果你去群里窥屏，萨姆，你能再说说它叫什么名字吗？它就叫“办公室女士播客粉丝专页”。太棒了。好吧，我们该去休息一下，然后回来进入这一集的内容。我们开始吧。好的。现在我们来到了《邓德·米夫林无限公司》第二部分。它从会议室的一个场景开始，对吧？迈克尔正在向大家展示所有的礼品篮。但是珍娜，有一个被删掉的场景本可以作为这部分内容的开端。那是什么？我很喜欢。我觉得它太迷人了。
And it's an alt. They ultimately end up providing this information with Dwight later, but there was a scene with Michael by himself. And it's the start of his day. And he's driving into work. He's doing one of those driving talking heads that Michael does, right? Oh, well, the last time he did that, it was very dangerous. I know. I know. He hit an employee. He did. So it's the same thing. He's driving into work and he's sort of showing off his rental car. It looks like a Ford, Taurus. I see Ford. I think, Taurus, I don't know, guys. Correct me if I'm wrong on that. But we learned the whole backstory why he's not driving the Sebring. Michael said he had to get a rental car because his Sebring is in the body shop because Meredith left a
这是一个替代版本。他们最终在后面通过德怀特提供了这些信息，但原本有一个迈克尔独处的场景。那是他一天的开始。他正开车去上班。他在做迈克尔常做的那种开车时的“谈话头”访谈，对吧？哦，好吧，他上次这么做的时候，非常危险。我知道。我知道。他撞了一个员工。他确实撞了。所以是一样的。他开车去上班，有点像在炫耀他的租来的车。看起来像是一辆福特，金牛座。我看是福特。我想，金牛座，我不知道，各位。如果我在这方面说错了请纠正我。但我们了解了全貌，知道了为什么他没有开赛百灵。迈克尔说他不得不租一辆车，因为他的赛百灵在修理厂里，因为梅雷迪思在引擎盖上撞出了
big dent in the hood. And then he said, but listen, this rental has navigation. And Michael calls it his invisible driving companion. And he goes, but, you know, listen, it is really amazing. And it's like a computerized map in your car. And he goes on to say that he loves its voice, that he finds it so soothing. It's like taking a warm bath. And while he's saying how much he loves the voice, Jan calls. And this is what we hear. Sam, will you play that? Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Ah, it is my lady love. Smell-o. Where the f*** are my grape nuts? I don't... I just want to know, did you eat my grape nuts? Ah, no, I hate those things. Grow up, Michael. I love...
一个大凹痕。然后他说，但是听着，这辆租来的车有导航系统。迈克尔称它为他的隐形驾驶伴侣。他说，但是，你知道，听着，这真的很神奇。它就像是你车里的一台电脑地图。他接着说他很喜欢它的声音，觉得它非常舒缓。就像洗个热水澡一样。就在他说他有多么喜欢这个声音的时候，简打来了电话。这就是我们听到的。萨姆，你能放一下那个吗？哦，等等，等等，等等，等等。啊，是我的爱人。斯梅洛（Smell-o）。我的葡萄干麦片到底在哪儿？我不知道……我只想知道，你是不是吃了我的葡萄干麦片？啊，不，我讨厌那东西。成熟点，迈克尔。我爱……
Not a morning person. Oh, no. Oh, my God. And then after that, he sits in the car in silence, and he just hits the navigation button. So it just keeps talking to him. You have arrived. You know, it's like, he just needs something soothing. Oh, lady. Oh, wow. Wow. Just a window into his life with Jan. And maybe a little bit of the reason why he trusts the navigation so much, because it's just this soothing, invisible driving companion. Yeah, I get that. So yes, this episode actually does start with the conference room. Jenna, did you see the spread on that table? It was incredible. I remember it from shooting. They had excellent, excellent little snacks and treats. Excellent. In fact, Michael says that he got the finest gourmet items that Scranton has to
不是个早起的人。哦，不。哦，天哪。然后在那之后，他坐在车里保持沉默，然后他只是按了一下导航按钮。所以它就一直对他说。您已到达目的地。你知道，就像是，他只是需要一些舒缓的东西。哦，天哪。哦，哇。哇。这只是对他在简的生活中的一窥。也许这也稍微解释了为什么他这么信任这个导航，因为它只是这个舒缓的、隐形的驾驶伴侣。是的，我懂。所以是的，这一集确实是从会议室开始的。珍娜，你看到那张桌子上的阵仗了吗？太惊人了。我还记得拍摄的时候。他们有非常、非常棒的小零食和点心。太棒了。事实上，迈克尔说他得到了斯克兰顿所能提供的
offer. How much did this all cost? I love every time you ask that question. You are personally fascinated by how Michael funds all of his extracurriculars. And it's such a good question to ask. This is where Angela Martin, the accountant character, bleeds into your real personality. It is, because let me tell you, those baskets were not cheap. Look at those. I love baskets. My husband says my nickname should be baskets. I have a basket problem. If I see a basket, I'm going to buy it. And I'm telling you, those baskets are primo baskets. Angela, I know that you recently did a huge clean out of your garage. I did. Will you share with us how many baskets were in the garage? 37. Yeah. 37. How many did you keep? 12. I picked my 12th favorite.
最好的美食。这一切花了多少钱？我每次听到你问这个问题都觉得很好笑。你对迈克尔是如何资助他所有的课外活动感到由衷的好奇。这是一个非常好的问题。这就是会计角色安吉拉·马丁渗透到你真实性格中的地方。确实如此，因为我得告诉你，那些篮子可不便宜。看看那些。我喜欢篮子。我丈夫说我的绰号应该叫“篮子”。我有篮子强迫症。如果我看到一个篮子，我就会买下它。我告诉你，那些篮子是顶级的篮子。安吉拉，我知道你最近对车库进行了一次大清理。我做过。你愿意跟我们分享一下车库里有多少个篮子吗？37个。是的。37个。你留下了几个？12个。我挑了我最喜欢的12个。
And let me tell you, it was hard for me to let go. I donated them to a church in our neighborhood that does outreach. And I was very, very happy that they got my baskets, but it was hard to say goodbye. I felt like when you were leaving me messages about this, I was really proud of you for this progress. Thank you. With your basket issue. Thank you. Yeah. That's not counting how many baskets I have inside the house. That I'm using though, like I have a basket genna by the fireplace that I roll up and I put blankets in. And then I have a basket in my bedroom that I roll up and put blankets in. Listen, I have a lot of blankets around my house because my husband is a giant mountain man and I'm always freezing. He runs hot. I have baskets of blankets
而且我得告诉你，让我放手真的很难。我把它们捐给了我们社区里一个做外展服务的教堂。我非常、非常高兴他们收下了我的篮子，但要说再见还是很难。我觉得当你给我发关于这件事的信息时，我真的为你取得的这个进展感到骄傲。谢谢你。针对你的篮子问题。谢谢。是的。这还没算我屋里有多少个篮子呢。不过都是我在用的，比如珍娜，我在壁炉旁放了一个篮子，我把毛巾卷起来放进去。然后我在卧室里放了一个篮子，把毛巾卷起来放进去。听着，我家四周有很多毛巾，因为我丈夫是个巨大的山顶洞人，而我总是觉得冷。他很怕热。我到处都藏着装满毛巾的篮子。
stashed all around. Okay. That is the title of your autobiography, Baskets of Blanket by Angela Kinsey. With a side of donuts and a glass of wine. It's a very long title. One million copies already sold. Yep. All right. Well, Michael has this talking head where he explains what these baskets are all about. He says, you know, Ryan thinks everything is about emails and IMs. It's all about technology. But he's forgetting about the original instant message, which is a letter attached to a basket of food. Yeah, that's the original IM, you guys, in case you were wondering. Well, I guess speaking of the cost of these baskets, Dwight is going to turn in receipts for the cost of these gift baskets to Angela,
好吧，这就是你的自传的书名，《安吉拉·金斯利的毛巾篮》。配上一份甜甜圈和一杯红酒。这是一个非常长的书名。已经售出了一百万册。是的。好吧，迈克尔有一个“谈话头”访谈，他在其中解释了这些篮子的意义。他说，你知道，瑞安认为一切都是关于电子邮件和即时消息的。全都是关于科技。但他却忘记了最初的即时消息，那就是附在食物篮上的一封信。是的，各位，如果你想知道的话，那才是最初的即时消息。好吧，说到这些篮子的成本，德怀特要把这些礼品篮的成本收据交个安吉拉，
yeah, who is very, very icy toward him. Yeah. And before we get into the scene, Jenna, we've brought this up before, but for any of you that missed it, 22 minutes, 53 seconds, you can clearly see on the message board under THUS, THUS, the following caption. In case you haven't noticed, there's a lot of colorful Huey on this board. Well, it's interesting you mentioned that Angela, because we had several people write in about this whiteboard behind you. Katie, E, Julie Bird, and Christopher Neville all said that there's even more stuff on the board now. For example, there is an anger management appreciation day on Tuesday, the 23rd. On the 8th, there is an accounting department meeting, and it specifies, be prepared to show your work. And on the 10th,
是的，安吉拉对他非常、非常冷淡。是的。在我们进入这个场景之前，珍娜，我们以前提到过，但对于任何错过的人来说，在 22 分钟 53 秒时，你可以在“THUS”下方的留言板上清楚地看到以下字幕。如果你还没注意到的话，这个板上有相当多色彩缤纷的休伊（Huey）。好吧，你提到这个很有意思，安吉拉，因为有几个人写信给我们谈到你身后的这个白板。凯蒂·E、朱莉·伯德和克里斯托弗·内维尔都说现在板上的内容更多了。例如，周二23日有一个“情绪管理感恩日”。在8号，有一个“会计部门会议”，并且明确指出“准备好展示你的工作”。而在10号，
it says flex times, which interestingly enough includes Karen, even though she left. And under the flex times on the 10th, it says that Ryan will cover reception, even though he now works at corporate. Yeah. And what is a flex time? You know, when I worked in admin, you needed to give the front receptionist a break so that that person could go to lunch. And so the other admin desks would rotate in to sit at the desk for lunch. So I was usually the receptionist, and then each day, a different admin would take over my lunch hour because you couldn't have no one answering front reception or no one greeting guests. So I always assumed that's what it meant, that like flex time was who rotated to give Pam her lunch break. But I don't know. I would have loved to
上面写着“弹性时间”，有趣的是，其中包含了已经离职的凯伦。在10号的弹性时间下面，写着瑞安将负责前台接待，尽管他现在在总公司工作。是的。什么是弹性时间？你知道的，当我做行政工作时，你需要给前台接待人员休息时间，以便那个人可以去吃午饭。所以其他行政桌位会轮流去前台坐班吃午饭。所以我通常是接待员，然后每天由不同的行政人员接替我的午餐时间，因为你不能让前台没人接听或者没人接待客人。所以我一直以为那就是它的意思，就像弹性时间是指谁轮流给帕姆放午餐假一样。但我不知道。我本很想
seen that scene. I would have loved to seen like just a montage of like different people answering the phones. Well, yes. So Dwight Hansangela, the receipt for all the items in the baskets. And she's very icy towards him, Jenna. She just wants it to be business, just business. Yeah. And he says, I miss you. And she's like, elevators. Yeah. And then when they get to the elevators, Angela is making it very clear that it's over. And Dwight is kind of like, okay, okay, I do want to be friends. Plus a little extra. Also, I love you. This is one of my favorite things that Dwight ever says to Angela. I have seen this like stitched on a pillow. I've seen it on all of these Valentine's items. It's really cute. People have written this to their boyfriend or girlfriend. And they've
看到那个场景。我本很想看到一个由不同的人接听电话的蒙太奇片段。好吧，是的。所以德怀特把篮子里所有物品的收据交给了安吉拉。她对他非常冷淡，珍娜。她只想公事公办，只谈业务。是的。他说，我想念你。她说，电梯。是的。然后当他们走到电梯时，安吉拉明确表示一切都结束了。而德怀特有点像，好吧，好吧，我确实想做朋友。另外还有点别的。还有，我爱你。这是德怀特对安吉拉说过的我最喜欢的话之一。我见过把它绣在枕头上的。我在所有这些情人节商品上都见过。这真的很可爱。人们把这个写给他们的男友或女友。他们还在网上跟我分享过。
shared it with me online. But that plus a little extra also, I love you. It's so great. I actually broke up with a guy once and he was like, I get it. Totally cool. Can we still hook up? Yeah. And I was like, no, we cannot. That is not breaking up. Yeah. And he seemed genuinely confused about it, which makes me laugh because we're now going into the scene with Ryan and Kelly in the break room. What a mess, these two. Yeah. Ryan and Kelly are arguing. And Ryan is like, you lied about being pregnant. You lied. You don't understand. Yeah. Why that's a big deal. And Mindy as Kelly is so good in this. She's like, oh, why?
但那个“另外还有点别的。还有，我爱你”。真是太棒了。我曾经和一个男生分手，他当时说，我懂。完全酷。我们还能上床吗？是的。然后我说，不，我们不能。那不叫分手。是的。而且他对此表现得非常困惑，这让我大笑，因为我们现在要进入瑞安和凯莉在休息室的场景了。这两个人真是个烂摊子。是的。瑞安和凯莉在争吵。瑞安说，你谎称自己怀孕了。你撒谎了。你不明白。是的。为什么这是件大事。明迪饰演的凯莉在这里表现得太棒了。她说，哦，为什么？
He's like, we will never get back together. And she's like, why not? It's so good. It's really good. Well, now Pam and Jim are at front reception and they're being super flirty. Yeah. They're flirting. He's saying, you know, oh, is the magic gone now that we're public? And then Pam's being sort of sassy but flirty at the same time. Well, this is their new way of flirting, which is to pretend that they don't like each other or that they're breaking up. So they do this little bit. And this is a little window into how they still have their sense of humor, even though they're together. Don't worry, everybody. The magic
他说，我们再也回不去了。她说，为什么不呢？这太棒了。真的很好。现在帕姆和吉姆在前台，他们超级调情。是的。他们在调情。他说，你知道的，哦，既然我们公开了，魔法是不是就消失了？然后帕姆表现得很厚脸皮但同时又很调情。好吧，这是他们新的调情方式，就是假装他们互相讨厌或者他们要分手了。所以他们演了这么一出小戏。这让我们得以一窥他们如何在在一起后依然保持幽默感。别担心，各位，魔法
is not lost. Yeah. The magic isn't lost. We're just all going to have to watch them flirt now. Also, two things from Pam's desk. There is an orange kind of rust colored ceramic pot with a very sad tiny plant, you know, because Pam could care less about plants now like she ever really cared. But her focus is elsewhere. And then Jenna, Pam and Angela in real life have something in common. What? At 24 minutes, 22 seconds, you can see a whole bunch of yellow post-it notes that Pam has put in her desk area. Oh my gosh, Pam did like post-it notes. Pam and Angela like post-it notes. Yeah. Yeah, it's true. Yeah, I did a lot of prop post-it note work on the show. Well, you know who likes post-it notes in real life.
并没有消失。是的，魔法没有消失。我们只是都得看他们调情了。还有，从帕姆的桌上有两样东西。有一个橙色、有点像铁锈色的陶瓷罐，里面有一株非常可怜的小植物，你知道的，因为帕姆现在对植物一点也不关心，就像她以前真的关心过一样。但她的注意力在别处。然后珍娜，现实生活中的帕姆和安吉拉有一个共同点。什么？在 24 分钟 22 秒时，你可以看到帕姆在她的办公桌区域贴了厚厚一沓黄色的便利贴。哦天哪，帕姆确实喜欢便利贴。帕姆和安吉拉都喜欢便利贴。是的，没错。是的，我在剧里做了很多道具便利贴的工作。好吧，你知道现实生活中谁喜欢便利贴吗？
You. Me. You love a post-it. I love a post-it. Why are you not like some sort of spokesperson for post-it notes? I don't know. I actually did a campaign with post-its a few years ago and they sent me a humongous box of every kind of different type of post-it you could imagine. And I was over the moon. I did a crazy thing with post-it notes. It was early in the run of the office. Wired Magazine wanted me to do like a nude cover. Yeah, but I wasn't I wasn't nude. Their pitch was that I was covered in post-it notes. Yeah. And so they built me like a nude bodysuit and then I came out onto the set in this nude bodysuit and then like a prop person had to slowly cover me in post-it notes.
你。我。你超爱便利贴。我超爱便利贴。你怎么不去当某种便利贴的代言人呢？我不知道。几年前我其实跟便利贴合作过一个活动，他们寄给我一个巨大的盒子，里面有你能想象到的各种不同类型的便利贴。我当时高兴坏了。我用便利贴做了一件疯狂的事。那是《办公室》开播早期。连线杂志（Wired Magazine）想让我拍一张裸体封面。是的，但我不是裸体。他们的构思是我全身贴满便利贴。是的。所以他们给我做了一件像裸色紧身衣一样的衣服，然后我穿着这件裸色紧身衣来到片场，接着一个道具人员不得不慢慢地用便利贴把我全身覆盖住。
It was super odd. And I was like, I guess this is what you do when your TV show is a hit and they ask you to do the cover of a magazine. A man covers you in post-it notes. Jenna, you should have worn it to an award show. You would have been all the rage. Remember the lady at the Oscars? She was a wardrobe designer and she made her whole dress out of American Express cards, gold cards. Do you remember that? Yeah. Yeah. You could have shown up in a post-it note couture gown. Well, lady, I think we know who needs to show up in a post-it note couture gown to something and it's you. And this is in your future and it can still happen. Oh my God. So Michael is going to unveil his plan, you guys, to win back clients. He makes his big
这超级诡异。然后我想，我想当你的电视节目大火、他们邀请你登上杂志封面时，你大概就是这么做的。一个男人用便利贴把你盖住。珍娜，你真应该把它穿去颁奖典礼。你绝对会轰动全场的。还记得奥斯卡颁奖典礼上的那位女士吗？她是一个服装设计师，她的整件衣服都是用美国运通卡、金卡制作的。你还记得吗？是的。是的。你本可以穿着一件便利贴高级定制礼服出场的。好吧，女士，我想我们都知道谁应该穿着一件便利贴高级定制礼服出席某种场合，那就是你。这还在你的未来，而且仍然可能发生。天哪。所以迈克尔要公布他的计划了，各位，去赢回客户。他发布了他的重大
announcement. He's going to be delivering baskets door to door and unannounced. He's not going to warn anyone he's coming. It's a surprise gift basket, everybody. Ryan's not happy. We have a Michael talking head where he's like, you know what? He used to be told he couldn't do things like be on the team or move on to second grade. Jenna, are we finding out in this episode that Michael was held back in first grade? Yeah, I think we are. I think we're learning maybe he was held back more than once, it sort of sounds like. Yeah, because then he's like, I eventually went on to second grade and I was the biggest in the class. Eventually? Again, what happened in Michael's childhood? Why was he held back in first grade so many times? And now we cut back to the bullpen.
公告。他要挨家挨户、毫无预兆地亲自递送礼品篮。他不会提前通知任何人他要来。这是一个惊喜礼品篮，大家。瑞安很不高兴。我们有一个迈克尔的“谈话头”访谈，他在其中说，你知道吗？他以前经常被人告知他不能做某些事，比如加入团队或者升入二年级。珍娜，我们在这集里发现迈克尔留级过一年级吗？是的，我想我们发现了。我想我们了解到也许他留级不止一次，听起来有点像。是的，因为接着他说，我后来终于升到了二年级，我是班里个子最大的。终于？话说回来，迈克尔的童年到底发生了什么？为什么他在一年级留级了那么多回？现在我们切回大办公室。
And Jenna, people are starting to yell out things and we have some major fill of sass. She says, Michael, this is stupid. She just lays it out. Lays it out. Yeah. And then Andy suggests he give away cash instead. Yeah. And then he says, Angela, cash basket. You guys, cash basket became an inside joke for all of us on the office for years and years and years. Every once in a while, there would be some line or some joke that it just struck us as particularly funny in the moment and we couldn't get over it. And cash basket was one of them. I think if my memory serves Angela, there was a take where Ed was maybe late to saying cash basket. And so it came out like this. Cash basket. And that made John Krasinski lose it.
然后珍娜，大家开始大喊大叫，我们有一些菲利斯的精彩吐槽。她说，迈克尔，这太蠢了。她直接挑明了。直接挑明了。是的。然后安迪建议他直接发现金作为替代。是的。然后他说，安吉拉，现金篮。各位，“现金篮”成了我们在《办公室》剧组多年来内部的一个笑话。每隔一段时间，就会有一些台词或笑话在当时让我们觉得格外搞笑，以至于我们挥之不去。“现金篮”就是其中之一。安吉拉，如果我的记忆没出错的话，有一个镜头里埃德说“现金篮”时可能说晚了。所以它出来的时候是这样的：现金篮。这让约翰·卡拉辛斯基彻底笑喷了。
Well, I think it was the very first take and a few things happened. We hadn't really heard him say it full out, right? Yeah. So it kind of took all of us off guard. And John was like right there next to him when Ed was like, cash basket. And we just lost it. But John really, he really lost it. I watched really closely because I was surprised they had a reaction shot of John at all in the scene because my memory of doing the scene was that John was on the floor in tears laughing the entire time because he couldn't get past cash basket. Well, I did notice though, because I was looking as well. He kind of is swiveling his chair around, but he glances back towards Andy. And that is just John looking at Ed. That is not Jim looking at Andy. He just has
嗯，我觉得那是第一条，而且发生了一些事情。我们之前没听过他那样大声说出来，对吧？是的。所以这让我们所有人都有点措手不及。当埃德喊出“现金篮”时，约翰就在他旁边。我们简直笑崩了。但约翰真的，他真的笑崩了。我看得非常仔细，因为我很惊讶他们在那个场景里竟然剪了约翰的反应镜头，因为我拍那个场景的记忆是约翰当时笑得眼泪直流、倒在地板上，整场都笑得停不下来，因为他根本过不去“现金篮”这个坎。不过我确实注意到了，因为我当时也在看。他有点把椅子转过来，但他的目光回看了一下安迪。那其实是约翰在看着埃德。那根本不是吉姆在看着安迪。他只是
this look of like, man, this guy is killing me today. Well, after I watched this episode, it really made me want to go to our office text thread and just text cash basket. Cash basket. Oh, we should. Well, Michael is just like, forget it, guys. I am going. I'm going to do this. And then Dwight begs him, can I please go with you? I need this. And at 26 minutes 41 seconds, Angela Martin is looking over the partition. She has a really great eye roll. But guys, look how high my head is over that partition. It's not realistic at all. Really and truly, that partition came up to my forehead. And I would have to stand on my tippy toes to get my eyeballs over it to talk to Jenna. I was standing on the biggest Apple box. It made me laugh when I saw
带着一种“天哪，这家伙今天快把我笑死了”的表情。好吧，看完这一集后，它真的让我很想去我们的办公室微信群里直接发一句“现金篮”。现金篮。哦，我们应该的。好吧，迈克尔简直就像是，算了吧，伙计们。我要去了。我要去这么做。然后德怀特求他，我能跟你一起去吗？我需要这个。在 26 分钟 41 秒时，安吉拉·马丁正从隔板上方张望。她有一个非常棒的白眼。但是大家看，我的头高出那个隔板多少啊。一点都不真实。真的、真的，那个隔板只到我的额头。我得踮起脚尖，才能把眼球露出来跟珍娜说话。我当时踩在一个最大的苹果箱上。我看到的时候都笑死了。
it. I'm like, who is this tall person pretending to be me? And I took a picture, Jenna, I'm going to show you. That is amazing. Yes, there is no way that that is you standing there because your chin never cleared the partition. I know, I know. Naturally. No, there's no way. Well, I really like this Michael talking head that comes up, Angela, where he says, I'd like to see a website deliver baskets of food to people. I know, as if it's like a novelty. Hi, that's like half of Christmas is just sending people baskets. I send everyone in my family a whole thing of mixed nuts. I love nuts. They're a big hit. A basket of mixed nuts. Yes, all kinds of mixed nuts. For sure. And there's, I mean, guys, there's many flavors. There's the Cajun nuts. There's pecans
我想，这个假装是我的高个子人是谁？我还拍了张照片，珍娜，我要给你看。太惊人了。是的，那绝对不可能是你站在那里，因为你的下巴从来没有越过隔板。我知道，我知道。自然状态下绝对没有。绝不可能。好吧，我很喜欢接下来这个迈克尔的“谈话头”访谈，安吉拉，他说，我倒想看看哪个网站能把食物篮送到人们手里。我知道，就好像这是个什么新鲜事一样。嗨，这就好比圣诞节有一半的内容只是给人送篮子。我给我家的每个人都寄整整一箱混合坚果。我喜欢坚果。它们很受欢迎。一篮混合坚果。是的，各种混合坚果。肯定的。而且，我的意思是，各位，有很多口味。有卡津风味坚果。有山核桃
or the caramelized ones. Just saying, Michael, people are doing it. Well, Michael is going to bring Dwight with him. And they're going to deliver these gift baskets. And they are in the car now, they're on their way. Here's one question I have. And yeah, these gift baskets are very, very large. Where are they? Where are they? Are they going back and forth to Dunder Mifflin? It looks like there's one in the backseat. Well, there's a camera operator in the backseat clearly filming them. It seems like there's only room for one more, but we're going to see them deliver a few. Where are they coming from? Is that can one fit in the trunk? I don't know. I wondered where the basket. How big is the trunk of a Ford Taurus? That's a question. That's a question. Well,
或者是焦糖味的。我是说，迈克尔，大家都在这么做。好吧，迈克尔要带上德怀特。他们要运送这些礼品篮。他们现在在车里，在路上了。我有一个疑问。话说回来，这些礼品篮非常、非常大。它们在哪儿？它们在哪儿？他们是来回跑回邓德·米夫林吗？看起来后座上有一个。好吧，后座上显然有一个摄像师在拍他们。看起来好像只剩下一个人的空间了，但我们会看到他们送了好几个。它们是从哪儿拿的？后备箱能塞下一个吗？我不知道。我很想知道这些篮子在哪儿。福特金牛座的后备箱有多大？这是个问题。这是一个问题。好吧，
I have a thing I'm curious about. So Michael and Dwight are in the car. They're driving. The GPS starts talking to them. By the way, it looks like a Garmin. I remember because I had one for a while, just saying. And Dwight's like, why do you use that? It'll let them know where you are. Michael's like, where are you talking about? And he's like, the government, spy satellites, private detectives, ex-girlfriends. And then he starts to cry. And Michael has no reaction. Wouldn't you be like, why are you crying? What is happening? Yeah. Dude's not like dudes out there. If your friend cries, are you not like, what's up? Are you just like, I'm gonna ignore it. Maybe he'll stop. Like, what is that? Is that a,
我有一件事很好奇。所以迈克尔和德怀特在车里。他们在开车。GPS 开始跟他们说话。顺便说一句，看起来像是一个 Garmin 导航仪。我记得因为我有一段时间也有一个，随口一提。德怀特问，你为什么用那个？它会让别人知道你在哪儿。迈克尔说，你在说什么呢？然后他说，政府、间谍卫星、私家侦探、前女友。然后他开始哭泣。而迈克尔没有任何反应。难道你不会问，你为什么哭？发生什么事了？是的。这家伙一点也不像外面那些正常的家伙。如果你的朋友哭了，你难道不会问，怎么了？难道你只会想，我要无视他。也许他会停下来。拜托，那是什么？那是，
is that a dude bro thing? I don't know. Well, we had a fan question about this scene. Callie Hendricks and Brendan Cullinan asked, how did you guys do the GPS voicing? Was it a voice actor? And if so, who voiced it? Yes, it was. It was a voice actor. It was an actress named Lynn Ann Zager. And we just hired her and she read all the GPS voice stuff. Well, she did great. She sounds like the real deal. I know. Jenna, my friend, Micah, you know, he's from Australia. And he set his GPS to the Aussie, the Aussie lady. So she's like, Oh, take a ride. No, you can do that. Yes, you can. You can have, like, like, I know you can have British, but he picked the Australian.
那是直男做的事吗？我不知道。好吧，我们有一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问。卡莉·亨德里克斯和布伦丹·库利南问，你们是怎么录制GPS语音的？是个配音演员吗？如果是的话，是谁配的？是的，没错。是个配音演员。是一个叫琳恩·安·扎格的女演员。我们雇了她，她读了所有GPS的语音内容。嗯，她做得很好。听起来跟真的一样。我知道。珍娜，我的朋友迈卡，你知道的，他是澳大利亚人。他把他的GPS设置成了澳洲口音，澳洲女士。所以她会说，哦，拐个弯。不，你可以那样做。是的，你可以。你可以有，比如，我知道你可以有英国口音，但他选了澳大利亚口音。
Oh, I kind of want to do this now. Yeah, I know. Is that great? Exit for Studio City. Oh, my God, I kind of love that. You know, there's this app, this meditation app called Headspace. I don't know if you've ever heard of it. And you can choose between either a male or a female, I guess, meditation leader voice. I don't know what to call them, but they lead you through the meditation and you can pick a man or a woman. And the man sounds exactly like our ear wolf producer, Colin. Really? Yes, to the point where I had to change to the woman, because as much as I love Colin's voice, I felt like I was like, I was like, why is Colin who talks to me about download numbers and ad sales
哦，我突然有点想这么做了。是啊，我知道。这不是很棒吗？在演播室城出口。哦，天哪，我有点喜欢这个。你知道，有个应用，这个冥想应用叫Headspace。我不知道你有没有听说过。你可以选择男性或女性，我猜，冥想引导员的声音。我不知道该怎么称呼他们，但他们引导你完成冥想，你可以选择男人或女人。而那个男的声音听起来跟我们的ear wolf制作人科兰一模一样。真的吗？是的，像到我不得不换成女声，因为尽管我喜欢科兰的声音，我觉得我当时就想，我就想，为什么一个跟我讨论下载量和广告销售的科兰
leading me through my meditation right now? It's really funny. Jenna, what if we did navigation for people? Oh, my gosh, what would that sound like? It would sound like this. Lady, take a right. You are at your destination. I love it. Oh, that's really good. All right. We should get back to the episode. Oh, man. Oh, man. I loved the scene. It's in the kitchen and Ryan is trying to impress Andy and Kevin about his life in New York City. And he's like, yeah, at 2am, you know, I went to get a sandwich because you can get a sandwich at 2am in New York City. He literally bumps into Vince Vaughn. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's incredible. And Andy says, you are so money, but you don't even know it. But you do know it. And that was a quote from
现在在引导我冥想？这真的很有趣。珍娜，如果我们为人们提供导航会怎么样？哦，天哪，那听起来会是什么样？听起来会是这样的。女士，向右转。你已到达目的地。我喜欢。哦，这真的很棒。好吧。我们应该回到这一集。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我很喜欢这个场景。在厨房里，瑞安正试图在安迪和凯文面前炫耀他在纽约市的生活。他就像是，对啊，凌晨2点，你知道的，我去买三明治，因为你可以在凌晨2点在纽约市买到三明治。他 literalmente（字面意思）撞到了文斯·沃恩。对。对。对。这太不可思议了。安迪说，你太有钱了，但你甚至不知道。但你确实知道。而那是出自
the movie Swingers. Yeah. Do you remember that movie? It was from 1996. How could I forget that movie? It was like, all of my friends were struggling actors. We were all broke and doing all these different odd jobs to pay rent while trying to go on auditions. And it was like this movie we like felt seen. We're like, this is us. Yes. Oh my God. It totally encapsulated the sort of like young LA transplant lifestyle. And it was written by John Favreau and stars John Favreau and Vince Vaughn and Ron Livingston. Yes. Directed by Doug Lyman. It launched all of their careers. I remember this. It features that club, the Dresden. Yeah. Do you remember the Dresden? It was this big swing dance club. Very hipster club. Yeah. Yeah. Well, it's here are the things. I have to
电影《求爱俗辣》。对。你还记得那部电影吗？那是1996年的。我怎么会忘那部电影？当时就像，我所有的朋友都是苦苦挣扎的演员。我们都破产了，做着各种不同的杂工来付房租，同时努力去参加试镜。那就像是一部让我们觉得被看到的电影。我们想，这就是我们。是的。哦，天哪。它完全概括了那种年轻的洛杉矶外地人的生活方式。它是由乔恩·费儒编剧的，主演有乔恩·费儒、文斯·沃恩和龙·利文斯顿。是的。道格·里曼导演的。它开启了他们所有人的职业生涯。我记得这个。里面有那个俱乐部，德累斯顿。对。你记得德累斯顿吗？那是个大型摇滚舞俱乐部。非常嬉皮士的俱乐部。对。对。好吧，事情是这样的。我得
read this off because it really got me tickled. You know, Jim is like, I can't believe you guys are impressed with this guy. You know, he's like, whatever with Ryan and his 2am sandwich, you know. And Andy's like, listen, this is why Ryan is awesome. Are you ready? Yeah. Number one, killer job. Number two, he's rich. Number three, smells like Pierce Brosnan. Number four, wears really cool rich guy clothes. Number five can get any girl he wants. We'll see. We'll see. Well, now Michael and Dwight arrive to their first client. They're going to woo him back with their big gift basket. He is confused why they've come. Yeah. Also, he's like, you don't have a website. We went with Office Depot because they have a really good website.
把这个读出来，因为它真的把我逗乐了。你知道，吉姆就像是，我简直不敢相信你们会对这家伙印象深刻。你知道，他就像是，随便吧，管他瑞安和他的凌晨2点三明治，你知道的。然后安迪说，听着，这就是为什么瑞安这么棒。准备好了吗？第一，超赞的工作。第二，他很有钱。第三，闻起来像皮尔斯·布鲁斯南。第四，穿着非常酷的有钱人衣服。第五，能钓到他想要的任何女孩。我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。好吧，现在迈克尔和德怀特到达了他们的第一个客户那里。他们要用他们的大礼篮把他争取回来。他很困惑他们为什么来。对。还有，他就像是，你们连个网站都没有。我们选择了Office Depot（办公仓库），因为他们有一个非常棒的网站。
Like what? I don't know why you're here. Yeah. It's a very funny scene. The actor who plays the client is named Edward James Gage who in addition to numerous acting roles also spent 13 years as a real life private eye bounty hunter and bodyguard according to his bio on IMDB. Okay. Well, that's a pretty interesting resume there. Well, I have a question about this scene. I'm I was a little confused what this business was. So the character's name is Larry, the client's name is Larry. And if you look over his shoulder, what is the crazy machine behind him? I've never seen anything like it. What is it? I don't know. And then it got me wondering, what is this company? Where have they gone? Do we ever find out? It was it bothered me. It was a big mystery for me. It did not bother
像什么？我不知道你们为什么来。对。这是一个非常有趣的场景。扮演客户的演员名叫爱德华·根据他在IMDB上的个人资料，詹姆斯·盖奇除了扮演过无数角色外，还当过13年的现实生活中的私人侦探、赏金猎人和保镖。好吧，那简历还挺有意思的。嗯，我对这个场景有个问题。我有点搞不懂这是一家什么公司。所以角色的名字叫拉里，客户的名字叫拉里。如果你越过他的肩膀看，他身后的那个疯狂机器是什么？我从来没见过那样的东西。那是什么？我不知道。然后这让我纳闷，这家公司是干什么的？他们去哪了？我们后来知道了么？这让我很困扰。对我来说这是一个巨大的谜团。这并没有困扰
me, but didn't bother you. Didn't occur to you. Now I guess I have to go back and look at this machine. Guys, check it out. What is it? There must be someone out there who knows what it is. They're going to be like, oh, they make widgets for plastic airplanes. Like it'll be obvious to someone and I'd love to know. Okay, me too. Me too. Well, back at Dunder Mifflin, Ryan is going to do a real skeezy boss move. He's going to go up to Pam and be like, Hey, do you want to do some mockups of the new, you know, Dunder Mifflin Infinity graphic? And, and she's really excited. Her and Jim do an air high five. And then you have a very adorable talking hedge. And I literally wrote, she's adorable. Okay. You're just like, yeah, I'm going to do some mockups, maybe a splash
我，但没困扰你吗？你没想到。现在我得回去看看这台机器了。伙计们，来看看。那是什么？外面一定有人知道那是什么。他们会觉得，哦，他们为塑料飞机生产小零件呢。对某人来说这会很明显，我很想知道。好吧，我也是。我也是。好吧，回到邓德·米夫林，瑞安要做一个非常卑鄙的老板举动。他要走到潘身边，好像在说，嘿，你想做一些新的，你知道的，邓德·米夫林无限公司图形的样机吗？而且，她真的很兴奋。她和吉姆击了个空气掌。然后你有一个非常可爱的会说话的树篱。我literally（字面意思）写了，她很可爱。好吧。你就像是，是的，我要做一些样机，也许是一个闪屏
frame. It's really cute. But you're excited. Well, Michael is going to deliver his second basket now. Second basket. Yeah, exactly. And this is where Michael is so great. I have to say, Michael's argument that the personal touch means something. He walks in, he asks about the client's 11 year old daughter, Emily, he remembered her name. He remembered she had a nut allergy. I mean, yeah, impressive. And genuine. Yeah. But then he has that line that breaks your heart. Oh, I know. I know what you're going to say. Yeah, he says, Well, I have a few of my own I want someday. Talking about kids. Yeah. Yeah. Michael. Well, the client's name is Aaron Grandy. He is a partner in this law firm. And he was played by Kevin Dorff. Kevin Dorff has had recurring roles on
。这真的很可爱。但你很兴奋。好吧，迈克尔现在要送他的第二个篮子了。第二个篮子。对，没错。这就是迈克尔最棒的地方。我得说，迈克尔关于个人触感意味着什么的论点。他走进来，询问客户11岁的女儿埃米莉的情况，他记得她的名字。他记得她坚果过敏。我是说，是的，令人印象深刻。而且很真诚。对。但随后他说了一句让你心碎的话。哦，我懂。我知道你要说什么。对，他说，嗯，我希望将来有一天我能有几个。谈到孩子。对。对。迈克尔。好吧，客户的名字叫亚伦·格兰迪。他是这家律所的合伙人。他由凯文·多尔夫饰演。凯文·多尔夫曾在
Brooklyn Nine-Nine and Arrested Development. But most recently, he played Bill O'Reilly in the movie Bombshell. And I loved that movie. I haven't seen it. Is it Bombshell? Oh, is it a war movie? Is it like bomb? No, lady, it's not a war movie. It's a little bit of a war movie because there are a couple of women who take on a movement, I guess you could say. It's it's this amazing film. It's basically centers around Megan Kelly and Gretchen Carlson and their time at Fox News. They were their news anchors. News anchors at Fox News or were and Kevin Dorff plays Bill O'Reilly in this movie. Oh, wow. It's so good, Angela. And the makeup department on this film won an Academy Award and the transformation that they do to make people look like the real people.
《神烦警探》和《发展受阻》中出演常规角色。但最近，他在电影《性感炸弹》中饰演了比尔·奥赖利。我很喜欢那部电影。我没看过。是《性感炸弹》吗？哦，这是一部战争电影吗？就像炸弹一样？不，女士，这不是战争电影。这有点像战争电影，因为有几个女人发起了一场运动，你可以这么说。这是一部了不起的电影。它基本上围绕着梅根·凯利和格雷琴·卡尔森以及他们在福克斯新闻的时间。他们是新闻主播。福克斯新闻的主播，或者曾经是，而凯文·多尔夫在这部电影中扮演比尔·奥赖利。哦，哇。太棒了，安吉拉。这部电影的化妆部门获得了奥斯卡奖，他们为了让演员看起来像真人而进行的改造。
Like Charlize Theron plays Megan Kelly. She really, really looks like her. Like it freaked me out. I once shared a train with Megan Kelly. I didn't speak to her, but I sat right across from her on a train from New York to Washington, D.C. And so I've I've seen her in real life as well. And I'm telling you what this makeup department did was I've never seen anything like it, but also the movie is amazing. Okay, well, Jenna, I'll add Bombshell to my queue. Please do. And we'll discuss after. Okay. And how cool that how cool that Kevin has a part in it? I know. I also want to say in this scene, though, the background acting behind the glass doors over the client's shoulder, you get a glimpse at the law firm. It is hustle and bustle in there.
就像查理兹·塞隆饰演梅根·凯利。她真的，真的看起来很像她。这把我吓坏了。我曾经和梅根·凯利共乘一辆火车。我没跟她说话，但我坐在她对面，从纽约到华盛顿特区的火车上。所以我现实生活中也见过她。我告诉你，这个化妆部门做的事，我从来没见过这样的，而且这部电影太棒了。好吧，珍娜，我会把《性感炸弹》加入我的片单。请务必这么做。我们看完讨论。好的。凯文能在其中扮演角色，不是很酷吗？我知道。我还想说，在这个场景中，客户肩膀上方玻璃门后面的背景群演，你可以瞥见这家律所。里面非常热闹。
There is so much going on. I mean, the background work is phenomenal. They're moving. They're moving and they're making it. They're making it. Yeah. Well, Michael's really trying hard. He wants this client back. He says, we want you back. And Dwight starts getting a little weird, because he's just thinking about Angela. And he goes, we had our chance and we killed it. And you just you just have this feeling that this is not going to go well for them. Yeah. Well, it's definitely not going to go well, because the big moment is about to happen. I think we should take a break. I like how you're setting this up, though. The big moment is about to happen. It's a big moment. It was a big stunt. Hey, it's not every day you drive a car into a
有那么多事情在发生。我是说，背景工作太出色了。他们在动。他们在动，他们在创造。他们在创造。对。好吧，迈克尔真的很努力。他想把这个客户赢回来。他说，我们要你回来。德怀特开始变得有点奇怪，因为他只想着安吉拉，他说，我们有机会，但我们把它搞砸了。你会有一种预感，这对他俩来说不会有好结果。对。好吧，这绝对不会有好结果，因为重大时刻就要发生了。我想我们应该休息一下。不过我喜欢你铺垫的方式。重大时刻就要发生了。这是一个重大时刻。这是一个特技。嘿，不是每天你都能把车开进
lake, guys. And we're going to tell you all about it after this break. All right, we are back. Jen and I are really excited because we have fun stuff to share with you about this car going into the lake. So here's the scene. Dwight says they have one more client. It's Elmhurst Country Club. I looked it up, Jenna. Elmhurst Country Club is in Moscow, Pennsylvania in Lackawanna County. So they're following the GPS and it's telling them to take a right. And Dwight is like, Michael, I think it means bear right, right? And Michael's like, no, it's telling me to take a hard right. And Dwight's like, no, Michael, that's the lake. It's like Scranton. And Michael's like, no, it's the GPS is telling me.
湖里，伙计们。休息过后，我们会把一切都告诉你们。好的，我们回来了。我和珍娜真的很兴奋，因为我们有一些有趣的事情要跟你们分享关于这辆车开进湖里的事。所以场景是这样的。德怀特说他们还有一个客户。是埃尔姆赫斯特乡村俱乐部。我查过了，珍娜。埃尔姆赫斯特乡村俱乐部在宾夕法尼亚州莫斯科的拉克瓦纳县。所以他们跟着GPS，GPS告诉他们向右转。德怀特就说，迈克尔，我觉得它是指靠右行驶吧？迈克尔就说，不，它告诉我要急转弯。德怀特就说，不，迈克尔，那是湖。就像斯克兰顿。迈克尔就说，不，是GPS告诉我的。
And he drives into the lake right into the lake. Well, we got a lot of mail about this scene. David B, Rachel K, Rob Holland, Thomas O'Brien, and many others all asked, please tell us everything you can about the scene where Steve and Rain drive into the lake. Did they really drive a car into the lake? Was there a camera operator in the back seat? Yes, folks. Let's break it down. But yes to all of that. Well, I started by reaching out to Steve and he said, yes, they really drove a real car into a real lake. He said they did the stunt twice all the way through and that Randall, our camera operator was in the back seat. So of course, Angela, I had to reach out to Randall.
然后他把车开进了湖里，直接开进了湖里。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这个场景的信件。大卫·B、蕾切尔·K、罗布·霍兰、托马斯·奥布莱恩以及许多其他人都在问，请把你们所知道的关于史蒂夫和雷恩把车开进湖里的那个场景的一切都告诉我们。他们是真的把车开进湖里了吗？后座上有摄影师吗？是的，各位。让我们来剖析一下。但对所有这些问题的回答都是肯定的。好吧，我首先联系了史蒂夫，他说，是的，他们真的把一辆真车开进了一个真湖。他说他们把这个特技完整地做了两次，我们的摄像师兰德尔坐在后座上。所以当然了，安吉拉，我不得不联系兰德尔。
Oh, oh, what did he say? Well, first of all, do you know where he was when I reached out to him? Listen, knowing Randall, I mean, he was he on horseback somewhere? The guy is an adventure guy. There's was he skydiving? Where was he? He was just finishing up a river rafting trip in Idaho on a freezing cold lake. Of course. Of course. But because Randall is awesome, he still broke down the whole stunt for me, which is completely fascinating. From Idaho. From on his drive home from Idaho from the freezing cold lake. When I first reached out to him, he literally said, I'm just getting out of a lake, which was ironic. Perfect. But I'll call you on my drive home. I was like, all right, amazing. Great. All right. So he says,
哦，哦，他说什么了？首先，你知道我联系他时他在哪里吗？听着，了解兰德尔，我是说，他当时在某个地方骑马吗？这家伙是个冒险家。他当时在玩跳伞吗？他在哪？他刚结束在爱达荷州一条冰冷湖泊上的激流泛舟之旅。当然。当然。但因为兰德尔太棒了，他还是为我剖析了整个特技，这非常引人入胜。从爱达荷州。在他从爱达荷州冰冷湖泊驾车回家的路上。我第一次联系他时，他字面意思地说，我刚从湖里出来，这太讽刺了。太完美了。但我开车回家时会给你打电话。我当时想，好的，太棒了。很好。好吧，所以他说，
first off, they did not actually drive the car into the lake. They put the car on a system that hold it into the lake and stopped it at a certain depth. So there was a rig to make it look like they were driving into a lake was on some type of track pulley thing. Yes. Okay. And he said they did this because they needed to control how much water flooded into the car. Makes sense. Yeah. Yes. He said the car actually didn't even have an engine. They had to take it out. It didn't have a gas tank. It didn't have any oil. All of that was removed to submerge it in water. I found that interesting. Yeah. But he told me he really was scrunched in the back seat with a giant gift basket next to him. So he said at first they discussed just filming it on lipstick
首先，他们实际上并没有把车开进湖里。他们把车放在一个系统上，把车吊进湖里，并在一定深度停下。所以有一个装置让它看起来像是他们把车开进湖里，它在某种轨道滑轮装置上。是的。好吧。他说他们这样做是因为他们需要控制有多少水涌入车内。说得通。对。是的。他说这辆车实际上甚至没有引擎。他们必须把它拿出来。它没有油箱。它没有任何机油。所有这些都被移除了，为了把它浸在水里。我觉得这很有趣。是的。但 M 他告诉我，他真的蜷缩在后座上，旁边放着一个巨大的礼篮。所以他说一开始他们讨论只用遮阳板里的微型
cameras that were in the visors. You know, we've seen them do that before. But Randall felt very strongly that it should be shot using the handheld camera from the back seat. So he kind of fought for that. And is that because it just the look of it would be better? You would really feel that water coming in because it's just a better camera. Yeah. And you can't pan the lipstick cameras. Right. They're just like a... They're stationary. They only get that one little window that you're seeing. Whereas Randall with a handheld camera could get the whole view. Yes. Exactly. He said that the camera that he was using, it cost upwards of $130,000. Holy cow. And he could not get it wet. He was told, you cannot ruin this camera. And they put some kind of protective housing on it. But
摄像机来拍摄。你知道的，我们以前看他们这样做过。但兰德尔坚信应该用后座的手持摄像机来拍摄。所以他为此争取了一下。是因为这样视觉效果会更好吗？你会真正感觉到水涌进来，因为这是一台更好的摄像机。是的。而且你不能平移微型摄像机。对。它们就像是一个……它们是固定的。它们只能拍到你看到的那个小窗口。而兰德尔拿着手持摄像机可以拍到全景。是的。完全正确。他说他用的那个摄像机，造价高达13万美元。天哪。而且它不能弄湿。有人告诉他，你不能弄坏这台摄像机。他们在上面加了某种防护外壳。但是
he said he still had to lift his butt off the back seat to keep the camera from dipping into the water. Oh my God. No pressure. Also, Randall, I mean, he's a big guy and he's scrunched in the back of this Ford Taurus with a gift basket and a camera that costs like, I mean, my God, it's like... I mean, my God, it's like... As much as a house. A house. He's holding a house. Yes. He's holding a house, basically. Dang. He told me that for sound purposes, they had a wire on both Steve and Rain and they used these waterproof mic packs called the Countryman. No. Well... Which Randall knew about from Survivor. Because remember, he spent all that time on Survivor. Yes. He said they also put mics in the visors and they had boom operators standing outside of the car in water.
他说他仍然得把屁股抬离后座，以防摄像机浸入水中。天哪。压力山大。还有，兰德尔，我是说，他是个大块头，却蜷缩在这辆福特金牛座的后座里，旁边还放着一个礼篮和一个价值连城的摄像机，我是说，天哪，就像……我是说，天哪，就像……和一栋房子一样贵。一栋房子。他拿着一栋房子。是的。他基本上拿着一栋房子。该死。他告诉我，为了收音，他们在史蒂夫和雷恩身上都装了线，他们使用了这些防水麦克风包，叫做Countryman。没有。好吧……兰德尔从《幸存者》节目中知道了这一点。因为记住，他在《幸存者》里呆了很长时间。是的。他说他们还在遮阳板里放了麦克风，而且他们的挑杆操作员站在车外的水中。
So our boom guys were like in like those like rubber pants in the water. Yes. Randall confirmed that they did three takes but they were losing daylight on the last one and he's pretty certain that we used the first take because everybody's reactions to hitting the water were just so pure. Yeah. And he said that there are only two cut points in this scene. So the first cut point is when the camera pans down to the GPS. That's when they cut into the car being on the rig. I mean, you can't even tell. It's seamless. I watched it like five times and I couldn't figure out... They did a great job. How they did it. And he said, and then after that point, it is all one shot until you see the shot of the basket floating in the water. And that's when they cut away and they
所以我们的挑杆小哥就像穿着那种橡胶裤在水里。是的。兰德尔证实他们拍了三次，但最后一次快没日光了，他非常确定我们用的是第一次拍的，因为大家对撞到水的反应实在是太真实了。对。他说这个场景只有两个剪辑点。所以第一个剪辑点是摄像机向下平移到GPS的时候。那是他们切到车子在装置上的画面的时候。我是说，你甚至看不出来。天衣无缝。我看了五遍，都找不出……他们做得太棒了。他们是怎么做到的。他说，在这之后，直到你看到篮子漂浮在水中的画面之前，全都是一个长镜头。这就是他们切走并
reset to get all the stuff of Michael and Dwight crawling out of the lake. But all of that commotion of getting out of the car and like Steve hanging on to the passenger side window and opening the door, that was all one take. And that was what Randall was fighting for. He was saying lipstick cams could have never, ever captured that. Yeah. I have a question. As Steve is making his way out and he's clinging onto the side of the car, he opens the back passenger door and was that to let Randall out? Well, we had a lot of people write in about that. They said, is Michael trying to save the camera operator or the gift basket? Yeah. And I asked Randall and Randall said, my instinct would be the gift basket. He's like, I never thought that Michael was opening the door
重新设置以拍摄迈克尔和德怀特从湖里爬出来的所有东西的时候。但所有这些从车里爬出来以及史蒂夫抓着副驾驶侧车窗并打开车门的小风波，全都是一个长镜头。这就是兰德尔力争的。他在说微型摄像机绝对、绝对无法捕捉到那个。对。我有个问题。当史蒂夫往外挤并抓着车身时，他打开了后排乘客车门，那是为了放兰德尔出来吗？好吧，我们有很多人写信来问这个。他们说，迈克尔是想救摄像师还是礼篮？对。我问了兰德尔，兰德尔说，我的直觉是礼篮。他就像是，我从来没想过迈克尔是在为我开门。但我认为很有趣，我把功劳归于迈克尔。我以为迈克尔是想解放摄像师。对。好吧，在35分17秒时，有一个绝对完美的镜头，是我们的摄像师的影子投射在整个湖面上。我也看到了。我很惊讶我没看到挑杆麦克风的影子。我一直在找挑杆的影子，但没看到。我很印象深刻。不过，是的，摄像师的影子确实在那儿。好吧，珍娜，我联系了雷恩，因为我想问，雷恩，把车开进湖里是什么感觉？我发短信给他，他给我们发了一段音频。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？嗨，办公室女士们。我是雷恩。安吉拉打来电话问我是否还记得把车开进湖里的事。我主要的恐惧不是溺水、车子或类似的事情。
for me. But I thought it's funny, I gave credit to Michael. I thought Michael was trying to free the camera operator. Yeah. Well, at 35 minutes, 17 seconds, there is a absolutely perfect shot of our camera operator shadow across the lake. I saw that too. I was surprised I didn't see boom mic shadows. I was looking for boom shadows and I didn't see them. I was impressed. But yes, the camera operator shadow is there. Well, Jenna, I reached out to rain because I was like, rain, what was it like driving into the lake? I texted him and he sent us an audio clip. Sam, can you play it? Hi, office ladies. It's me, Rain. Angela called and asked me if I had any memories about driving into the lake. And my main fear wasn't like drowning or the car or anything like that.
而是觉得，这水不太干净。而且到处都是房子。我只知道这水里肯定有很多下水道污水。我真的很害怕得眼部感染之类的东西。这水感觉有点诡异的温暖。水一点也不冷。但超级好玩。我是说，我喜欢有机会演特技。我真的很兴奋能参与其中。我是说，你多久能有机会把自己的车开进湖里一次？太棒了，拍起来太有趣了。我希望能有更多细节。但这就是那种你会觉得，哇，这就是我今天谋生的方式的日子。我在扮演一个虚构的怪人，把我的车开进湖里。而且还有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我是说，这真是太棒了。好吧，我爱你。再见。
It was kind of like, this water is not the cleanest. And there's all these houses all over the place. And I just knew it was pretty sewagey. And I was just really afraid of an eye infection or something like that. It was like kind of eerily warm. The water was not cold at all. But it was super fun. I mean, I love a chance to do a stunt. I was really excited to be a part of it. And I mean, how often do you get to kind of drive your car into a lake? It was fantastic, so much fun to shoot. And I wish I had more specifics. But it was just one of those kind of days where you're kind of like, wow, this is what I do for a living today. I'm playing a fictional weirdo and driving my car into a lake. And with Steve Carell, I mean, it was pretty great. Okay, I love you. Goodbye.
我喜欢雷恩最大的担忧竟然是得红眼病。对，伙计们，我今天可不想长麦粒肿。今天不行。如果让我做这个特技，我会有太多的担忧了。他说水奇迹般地暖和，这确实让我有点恶心。你必须记住，我们是在马里布湖拍摄的，那是一个人工湖。所以没有像什么活水流进它里面，你知道的，它可能有点死水。我得指出一件事。当拖车把车拉出来时，珍娜，副驾驶车门是关着的，但迈克尔把它打开了。哦，对。然后我脑海里的另一件事是，迈克尔和德怀特恰好把车窗摇下来了吗，因为他们是从车窗爬出来的？我在想，他们开车时一直把车窗摇下来吗？所以
I love that rain's biggest concern was getting pink eye. Yeah, I don't want to get a sty today, guys. Not today. I would have had so many concerns doing this stunt. It did kind of gross me out that he said the water was oddly warm. And you have to remember, we filmed this at Malibu Lake, and that is a manmade lake. So there isn't like anything flowing into it, you know, it is probably a little stagnant. I have to point something out. When the tow truck pulls the car out, Jenna, the passenger door is shut, but Michael opened it. Oh, yeah. And then the other thing I was thinking about was, did Michael and Dwight just happen to have their windows down because they climb out through their windows? I'm like, were they driving around with their windows down? So
会有这样的小时刻，就让人觉得，呃，好吧，伙计们。好吧，安吉拉，当我通过电子邮件和史蒂夫讨论这个场景时，他提醒我，在这集播出后，因为这个时刻，我们遭到了很多反对。他说人们觉得有点太夸张了，有人会跟着GPS把车开进湖里是不切实际的。对，人们会觉得，绝不可能，那绝不会发生。但他告诉我，编剧们是以现实生活中一系列人们跟着GPS陷入危险境地的事件为基础的。所以我联系了格雷格，他说这是詹·萨拉达的一个点子。所以当然，我不得不顺藤摸瓜。我联系了詹。詹说了什么？
there are little moments like that that were just sort of like, I was like, huh, okay, guys. Well, when I was emailing with Steve about this scene, Angela, he reminded me that we got a lot of pushback after this episode aired because of this moment. He said people kind of thought it was a little over the top, that it was unrealistic that someone would follow their GPS into a lake. Yeah, people are like, no way that would never happen. But he told me that the writers based this on a series of real life incidents of people following their GPS into perilous situations. So I reached out to Greg and he said this was a pitch by Jen Salada. So of course, I had to follow this trail. I reached out to Jen. What did Jen say?
她说在第四季之前的假期里，她回家看望她在马里兰州的父母，她坐在他们崭新的小型货车的后座上。她具体说明是一辆本田奥德赛小型货车。她拿起车主手册，读起了小型货车GPS系统的信息。她说在手册的第一页，有一个警告，上面写着，不要把你的车开进任何水体，即使GPS告诉你这么做。詹当时就想，什么？谁会这么干？你知道，本田不得不把它写进去，因为确实有人干过。是的。她就想，等等，你知道谁会干这事吗？迈克尔·斯科特会干这事。是的，他会。所以她说在她提出这个点子之前，因为她
She said during the hiatus before season four, she went home to visit her parents in Maryland, and she was sitting in the backseat of their brand new minivan. She specified it was a Honda Odyssey minivan. She picked up the owner's manual and was reading about the minivan's GPS system. She said that on the very first page of the manual, there was a warning that said, do not drive your car into any bodies of water, even if the GPS tells you to. And Jen was like, what? Who would do that? You know, Honda had to put that in there because someone had done it. Yes. And she was like, wait a second, you know who would do that? Michael Scott would do that. Yes, he would. So she said before she pitched it, because she was
有点担心这个主意太疯狂了。她研究了这个现象，她说，有太多人因为GPS的指示把车开下悬崖或开进水里的案例了。她说通常这种情况是，比如某处有一座桥，它被拆除了，而GPS不知道，它就指示你开过一座根本不存在的桥。不管怎样，她把这个带进编剧室并提出了这个点子，她展示了所有关于为什么这真的会发生的证据，最后它就被写进了这一集。好吧，这太棒了，伙计们，她是正确的，因为我也用谷歌搜索过了。网上有太多人们因为GPS的指示把车开进各种地方的故事。在我读过的所有这些故事中
a little worried it was too crazy of an idea. She researched this phenomenon, and she said, there were so many cases of people doing things like driving their cars off of a cliff or into water because their GPS told them to. She said usually it was a case where like maybe there was a bridge somewhere and it had been taken down and the GPS didn't know and it told you to drive across a bridge that didn't exist. But anyway, she brought it into the room and she pitched it and she showed all of her evidence for why this could really happen and it made it into the episode. Well, it's fantastic and you guys, she is right because I Googled it as well. There are so many stories online of people driving their cars into things because the GPS told them to. Here of all of them that I
，有那么多，我都读不完。这里有两个例子，只是为了展示给你们看，好吗？好的，好的。2009年，罗伯特·琼斯在英格兰西约克郡使用导航，道路开始变得陡峭和狭窄，但它一直告诉他继续前进。它一直坚称这条路就是道路，他后来解释说，所以他信任了它。琼斯直到他的车撞上距离100英尺悬崖只有几英寸的一道细铁丝网时，才意识到自己错得多么离谱。车把他带到了边缘。就像边缘，根本没有路。他设法安全逃生，但车依然在边缘摇摇欲坠。救援队花了九个小时才把车拖走。哦，天哪。所以这不是一条路。它只是慢慢地，就像是一条路逐渐变窄
read and there were so many, I couldn't read them all. Here are two examples just to show you, okay? Okay, okay. In 2009, Robert Jones was using his navigation in West Yorkshire, England, and the road began to steepen and narrow, but it kept telling him to keep going. It kept insisting the path was the road, he later explained, so he trusted it. Jones only realized how wrong he was when his car bumped up against a thin wire fence just inches from a 100 foot drop. The car was taking him on the edge. Like the edge, there was no road. He managed to get out safely, but the car remained balanced on the edge. It took a recovery team nine hours to haul the car away. Oh my god. So this wasn't a road. It just was slowly, like it was like a road that like narrowed
成了这座山。就像悬崖边。是的。然后还有这个。2011年，三名女性去华盛顿州贝尔维尤游玩，她们在午夜过后外出，找不到她们的酒店，所以她们询问了GPS，对吧？这听起来是一件很正常的事。GPS为她们重新规划了路线，把她们带到了她们以为通往高速公路的一条路上。相反，她们的SUV最终沉入了深水中。那条路原来是一个游艇下水滑道。哦，天哪。是的。水是一个湖。三个人都设法安全逃生，但等拖车到达时，SUV已经完全被淹没了。引述低处的，这是当地的消防员，华盛顿州贝尔维尤的一名消防员这样说道，我们见过类似事情的情景喜剧戏仿，但实际
into this hill. It was like a cliff side. Yes. And then here's this. In 2011, three women were visiting Bellevue, Washington, and they were out after midnight and they were unable to find their hotel, so they asked GPS, right? That seems like a normal thing to do. GPS rerouted them and took them on what they thought was a road that would lead them to the highway. Instead, their SUV ended up sinking into deep water. The road turned out to be a boat launch. Oh my god. Yes. And the water was a lake. All three managed to get out safely, but by the time the tow truck arrived, the SUV was completely submerged. Quote from the low, and this is the local fireman, and Bellevue, Washington was quoted as saying this, we've seen sitcom parodies of something like this, but to actually
看到它还是令人惊讶。好吧，我确信他们指的是我们的节目。我也这么觉得。你知道，我和李刚开始约会时，我们去了法国。这是我们作为情侣的第一次大旅行。哦，听起来太有趣了。我们，是的，我们开车穿过法国乡村，我们租了一辆车，但GPS是法语的。我们当时没多想。好吧，我们讨论过，安吉拉，我懂一点法语。你懂一点点法语。所以我对李说，我来翻译。听起来这像是你们作为情侣将要爆发的第一次争吵。亲爱的，我来在一个你从来没开过车的外国翻译导航。好吧，问题在于我需要一会儿才能反应过来这些
see it is surprising. Well, I'm sure they were referring to our show. I think so. You know, when Lee and I were first dating, we went to France. This was our first big trip together as a couple. Oh, that sounds so fun. And we, yes, and we drove through the French countryside and we rented a car, but the GPS was in French. We weren't thinking. Well, we've discussed, Angela, that I know a little bit of French. You know a handful of French. So I say to Lee, I'll translate it. This sounds like your first fight as a couple about to happen. Honey, I'll translate the navigation in a foreign country where you're driving and you've never driven here before. Well, the problem was that it would take me a second to realize what the
方向是什么。所以有这样一个转弯，它会说，向右转，向右转。但我慢了一拍，我们错过了那个转弯。对。所以李绕了一个大圈才把我们带回这个地方。然后那个人会说，大转弯。而我会说，右，右，右，右。是向右转。我们因为我翻译不及时，像这样错过了那个转弯四次。但不仅如此。她不只是那样说。她就像是，有很多法语和街道名称，夹杂在其中的某个地方会像是，大转弯。而我会说，右，我想，右。我觉得如果当时是你和我在车里，我开车而你这么做的话，我骨子里的南方人血统就会爆发，我会说，
directions were. And so there was this one turn where it would be like, turn right, turn right. But I was behind and we missed the turn. Yeah. So Lee did this huge circle around to get us back to this spot. And the person would be like, turn a lot. And I'd be like, right, right, right, right. It's turn right. And we missed that turn like four times because of my lag in translating properly. But it was more than that. She wasn't just saying that. She was like, lots of French and names of streets and somewhere embedded in there would be like, turn a lot. And I'd be like, right, I think, right. I feel like if it was you and I in the car and I'm driving and you're doing that, I'd be like the real southerner in me would come out like,
她刚才是说arduat还是没说？我在做arduat吗？好吧，你知道李，安吉拉，他是地球上最淡定的人。哦，这男人，伙计们，他脾气太好了。他脾气太温和了。就像不可动摇的，不可动摇的。好吧，在我第四次错过大转弯后，他只是说，好吧，这算什么鬼，然后我就想，哦，天哪，我把他逼疯了。我打破了……这是你第一次听到他骂人。是的，他当时只是……我当时就想，哦，天哪，经历过法国之后他还爱我吗？我们……但实际上我们事后对此笑得前仰后合。对，我当时想，哦，天哪，我在法国把你逼疯了。我们笑了。好吧，你没有把他逼疯。导航女士把他逼疯了。哦，天哪，伙计们，如果你们去外国旅行，
did she say arduat or not? Am I doing arduat? Well, you know Lee Angela and he is the most level person on the planet. Oh, this man guys, he is so well tempered. He's so good natured. Like unshakable unshakable. Well, after the fourth time of me missing turn a lot, he just goes, well, what the and I was like, oh my God, I broke him. I broke like the first time you ever heard him curse. Yes, he was just I was like, oh my God, does he still love me after France? And we but actually we laughed so hard about it after that. Yeah, I was like, oh my God, I broke you in France. We laughed. Well, you didn't break him. The navigation lady broke him. Oh my gosh, guys, if you ever traveled to a foreign country, and you're thinking you'll just
并且认为你们只需依赖GPS，你们就得要求语言。听着，听着，我不会把我们带到那条路上，但乔什和我在苏格兰吵过一架，当时他必须在路的另一侧开车，试图做一个……现在换到环岛就像是，环岛真的很棒，它们真的很聪明。我们这个国家应该有环岛。它们是绝佳的发明。一开始它们让人应接不暇，因为作为美国司机，它们对我们来说非常陌生。但实际上，它们是控制交通流的好方法。我觉得自己需要深入研究一下环岛的历史。深入研究，它可能可以追溯到罗马人或什么的，但在靠道路另一侧驾驶的同时做一个环岛，并以你从未从那边驶出的方向驶出，这绝对是你们在车里爆发第一次大争吵的配方，我只是这么说。好吧，我在美国最看不惯的一点是，当我们确实有环岛时，我们在里面设置了停车标志，这根本不是环岛的意义所在。
rely on your GPS, you have to request the language. Listen, listen, I won't take us down that road, but Josh and I had a fight in Scotland where he had to be driving on the other side of the road trying to do a and now for a roundabout was like roundabouts are so great, though, they really are so smart. We should have roundabouts in this country. They are wonderful inventions. They're overwhelming at first, because they are very foreign to us as American drivers. But truly, they are a wonderful way to control the flow of traffic. I feel myself needing to deep dive on the history of roundabouts. Deep dive, it probably goes back to the Romans or something, but doing a roundabout driving on the opposite side of the road and exiting the
好吧，那不是你的做法。我们做得对。无论如何，好吧，伙计们，他们确实从湖里出来了，他们湿透了，他们从这一刻得到的最大收获，他们决心要做的事情是走回上一个客户的办公室，索回他们的礼篮。迈克尔说他们要表明立场。还有，德怀特的手机能用。他的翻盖手机。对，老科技警报。我不明白的是为什么他们
opposite way that you've never exited is a recipe for maybe one of your first big fights in a car, just saying. Well, my pet peeve in America is that when we do have roundabouts, we put stop signs in them, which is not the point of a roundabout. Well, that's not how you do it. We're doing it right. Anyway, okay, well, guys, they do get out of the lake, they're soaking wet, and their big takeaway from this moment, the thing that they feel determined to do is to walk back to the previous client's office and reclaim their gift basket. Michael says they're going to take a stand. Also, Dwight's phone works. His flip phone. Yeah, old tech alert. What I didn't understand about this was why they
不能直接叫辆出租车。他们非得走。对，我不知道。我不知道，因为德怀特的手机确实能用。但迈克尔说，不，我们要走。好吧，回到办公室，瑞安正在审阅潘为新的邓德·米夫林无限公司标志做的一些草图，顺便说一句，我觉得这些草图很棒。对，她做得很好。但瑞安来聊的真不是这个。不，他并不是真的来看她的草图。他只是想带她出去吃晚饭，他在偷偷摸摸的。对。好吧，她拒绝了他，这时她告诉他她在和吉姆约会。他就像是，不会吧。对。瑞安无法接受凯伦和潘都跟吉姆约会过却没跟他约会的事实。对。好吧，迈克尔和德怀特回到了这家律所。
couldn't just take a cab. They have to walk. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know because Dwight's phone does work. But Michael's like, no, we're walking. Well, back at the office, Ryan is reviewing some of Pam's sketches for the new Dunder Mifflin Infinity logo, which by the way, I thought were great. Yeah, she did a great job. But that's not what really Ryan was there to talk about. No, he wasn't really getting her sketches. He just wants to take her out to dinner and he's trying to be sneaky. Yeah. Well, she turns him down and this is when she informs him that she is dating Jim. He's like, no way. Yeah. Ryan cannot get over the fact that both Karen and Pam have dated Jim and not him. Yeah. Well, Michael and Dwight make it back to this law firm.
我太喜欢这个场景了。我看了三遍。太棒了。我是说，他们走进来时看起来糟糕透顶。他们掉进过湖里，穿着湿衣服走进来。对。而且，我是说，迈克尔看起来精神崩溃了。史蒂夫在这里的表演太棒了。它植根于如此多的真实、伤害、愤怒、失望。太棒了。他要求归还他们的礼篮。当那家伙终于把礼篮拿出来时，迈克尔注意到少了一样东西。海龟巧克力。海龟巧克力。他气得直爆粗口。可怜的亚伦。亚伦从没料到会有这一刻。他就像，是的，他为这些巧克力疯狂了。亚伦就像是，我吃了。它们是我的。这个礼篮有一会儿是属于我的。所以我吃里面东西了。但德怀特就像是，
I loved this scene so much. I watched it three times. It's so good. I mean, they walk in and they look horrible. They've been in a lake and they've walked in wet clothes. Yeah. And I mean, Michael seems unhinged. Steve's performance is so good here. It is rooted in so much truth and hurt and anger, disappointment. It is so good. He demands their gift basket back. When the guy finally brings the gift basket out, Michael notices that something is missing. The turtles. The turtles. And he loses his shiitake. Poor Aaron. Aaron never saw this moment coming. He's like, yeah, he loses his mind over these turtles. And Aaron is like, I ate them. They were mine. This gift basket was mine for a minute. So I ate things from it. But Dwight is like,
我们要把这个记在你的账单上。哦，天哪。这太不可思议了。他们刚刚做了这样一件事：他们本来可能还有机会把他争取回来，结果他们直接把桥给烧了。对。对。好吧，他们回到办公室。他们冲了进来。迈克尔宣称这个办公室将不再使用任何新技术的任何东西，因为他把车开进了一个湖里。一个该死的湖。好吧，奥斯卡就说，你干了什么？他就像，我把车开进了一个该死的湖。他们把它消音了。这很少见。我们在节目中不常消音，但偶尔，天哪，这样反而更搞笑。这样反而更搞笑。对。他还想让每个人都知道，与技术不同，礼篮从来没有危及过
we'll bill you for it. Oh my gosh. It's incredible stuff. They just did that thing where they might have had a chance of getting him back and then they just burned it to the ground. Yeah. Yeah. Well, they come back to the office. They storm in. Michael proclaims that this office will no longer be using any new technology of any kind because he drove his car into a lake. An effing lake. Well, Oscar is like, you did what? And he is like, I drove my car into an effing lake. And they bleep it out. And this was rare. We did not do a lot of bleeping on our show, but every once in a while, man, it's just funnier this way. It's just funnier this way. Yeah. He also wants everybody to know that unlike technology, gift baskets never endangered
任何人的生命。他基本上宣布自己获胜了。是的，他确实如此。在40分43秒时，安吉拉·马丁有一个非常大的翻白眼动作，因为迈克尔宣布自己是赢家。但他不仅宣布自己是赢家。这是他对他的新老板瑞安说的，他说，局盘赛点斯科特局结束游戏结束。然后他又试了一句，但他想不起来了。所以然后他就走进了他的办公室。这太棒了。这太棒了。迈克尔以一个最后的单人独白结束了这一切。我们看到我们所有人在会议室里吃着礼篮里的东西。我记得拍摄那个场景。记得吗？对，我们早些时候拍了那个场景，我们在看所有的东西。我
anybody's lives. And he basically declares himself triumphant. Yes, he does. And there's a very big Angela Martin eye roll at 40 minutes, 43 seconds, as Michael declares himself the winner. But he doesn't just declare himself the winner. This is what he says to Ryan, his new boss, he says, game set match point Scott game over end of game. And then he tries one more, but he can't think of it. So then he just walks into his office. It's so good. It is so good. Michael ends it all with a final talking head. And we see all of us eating from the gift basket in the conference room. I remember shooting that scene. Remember? Yeah, we shot the scene earlier where we were looking at all the things. And I
记得我等不及我们要拍我把这些全吃掉的场景了。我不在会议室里。安吉拉根本不吃这一套。对，太糟了，因为那些礼篮里确实有些好东西。有些好东西。我知道。我记得你们在现实生活中确实很兴奋地打开那些包裹。然后最终我们以瑞安的一个单人独白结束了这一集。他还在为他浮华的新生活洋洋得意。他说，你知道，他不是说他经历了火箭般的速度崛起，但你知道，但他猜他确实经历了，而且他的发型花了200美元。他简直就像个讨厌鬼。而且，女士，在瑞安吹嘘纽约的删减片段里有一些很棒的龙套演员。他和吉姆有一整段对话，比如，嗯，你知道，在纽约，而吉姆就像是，
remembered I can't wait until we do the scene where I get to eat all this. I was not in the conference room. Angela is having none of it. Yeah, it's too bad because they were some good gift. There were some good stuff. I know. I remember you guys were actually excited in real life to open up those packages. And then ultimately we end the episode with a Ryan talking head. He's still gloating about his new shmancy life. He says, you know, he's not saying he had a meteoric rise, but you know, but I guess he did and that his haircut was $200. He's just being such a tool. And lady, there are some great extras in the deleted scenes of Ryan bragging about New York. He has a whole thing with Jim about like, well, you know, in New York and Jim's like,
对，实际上，我去过那儿，而瑞安就像是，不，不，不，但那是不一样的。你得在那里生活。就像你不能，你不能真正理解我在说什么，因为你没有在那里生活过。所以，你知道，抱歉。对。但无论如何，它们真的很有趣。太可惜了。我真的很喜欢他和吉姆之间的那个场景。他就是不肯放过。好吧，就是这样，伙ites。Dunder Mifflin infinity（邓德·米夫林无限公司）到此结束。Dunder Mifflin infinity，接下来，珍娜，是什么？Launch party（发布派对）。Launch party。Launch party。凯文。这是一个派对。Launch party。好吧，伙计们，我们下周见。我们下周见。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由欧文、
yeah, I actually, I've been there and he's like, no, no, no, but it's different. You've got to live there. Like you don't, you can't really understand what I'm talking about because you haven't lived there. So, you know, sorry. Yeah. But anyway, they're really funny. That's too bad. I really loved the scene between him and Jim. He just would not let it go. Well, that's it guys. That finishes out Dunder Mifflin infinity. Dunder Mifflin infinity and up next, Jenna is what? Launch party. Launch party. Launch party. Kevin. It's a party. Launch party. All right, guys, we'll see you next week. We'll see you next week. Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin,
珍娜·费瑟和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费瑟。我们的录音师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用代码office。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of StitcherPremium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 StitcherPremium 一个月，请使用代码 office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。